ippon waza-ari du coup on a joué des
coudes sur les tatamis de guyancourt ce
week-end un tournoi pour les petits
judokas et est organisé au gymnase
maurice baquet cette compétition amicale
était destiné aux enfants âgés de 5 à 9
ans les habitants ont fui d'autres ont
pu découvrir à cette occasion les prises
de judo et les codes de ce sport on
écoute le président du club de hambourg
et les techniques rod williams
c'est une petite compétition qui nous
sert en fait à montrer aux enfants
comment se déroulent les compétitions
comment on peut faire déjà un peu
d'arbitrage ça nous sert aussi pour les
adolescents donc de commencer
l'arbitrage et puis d'avoir des notions
d'arbitrage et puis voilà c'est quoi ton
inhérents au judo d'avoir des parties de
compétition pour pour les entraîner et
un mot de baseball à présent les
couillard de montigny-le-bretonneux
l'ont remporté ce week-end la 20e
édition du tournoi de pâques costa de
jean maréchal une compétition amicale
organisée chaque année pour préparer
l'équipe en vue du championnat un
reportage signé michael d'euros
c'est désormais une tradition pour la
vingtième année consécutive les cougars
de montigny-le-bretonneux ont organisé
ce week-end le retour note bac 2 au
stade jean maréchal les fans de baseball
saint quentinois ont pu voir leurs
protégés mais également les gee moeurs
de saint lô les sense de saint-jean
mansle et les outlaws de strasbourg
cette année c'est plus un niveau
régional national une donc un petit peu
en dessous de notre division mais ça
reste quand même
un niveau correct pour pouvoir se
préparer de bonnes façons le tournoi de
pâques bien qu'amical est avant tout un
rendez-vous pour permettre aux cougars
de préparer le championnat de deuxième
division la saison débutera le dimanche
3 avril sur le terrain dissin l'intérêt
du tournoi c'est aussi de faire pas mal
de matchs donc de bien se préparer avant
la saison prendre pendant pas de voir
des lanceurs d'avoir du temps de jeu
pour arriver en pleine forme à la
semaine prochaine ces deux jours ont
également permis au public d'apercevoir
la nouvelle recrue américaine ryan
juares un lanceur d'origine
californienne qui a évolué à l'australie
la saison dernière le sportif devrait
être l'une des têtes d'affiché de
l'équipe cette année là c'est marrant
parce qu'il a on voit vraiment qu'il est
agressif dans le jeu et c'est ça qui
fait plaisir après il a vraiment le
style américain
vraiment joué le jeu ça qui est marrant
a bien lancé le premier match et un 10 0
la semaine dernière à montpellier l'a
réalisé une bonne performance contre une
équipe de notre division donc on est
vraiment confiant avec lui sur
denticules les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux ont remporté le tournoi de
pâques en battant en finale et sense de
sorges en anglais
et vous savez ce week-end c'était le
week-end de pâques nous n'allons pas
nous quitter avant un mot de chocolat
samedi dernier donc pour ce week-end la
ville d'el on peut organiser la
traditionnelle chasse aux oeufs plus
d'un millier d'enfants de 3 à 11 ans
étaient au parc des coudrais pour
remplir leurs paniers de chocolat
williams elle à chercher les oeufs avec
le regarder
a il encourt le week-end dernier le
faire que des coudrais april allures
d'un grand magasin un jour de soldes
pris d'assaut par 1500 enfants élan
courtois venu participer à la grande
chasse aux oeufs c'est une chasse aux
oeufs ou
on a distribué six mille oeufs sur tout
le parc des coudrais un oeuf égale un
oeuf en chocolat en échange et nous
avons 50 de l'eau donc
52e numérotés et ils viennent les
échanges et ici on a des places de ciné
à des places pour france miniature
beaucoup de chocolat une chasse qui
prend parfois des allures de course
l'objectif aujourd'hui ramasser un
maximum de en plastique pour venir
ensuite les échanger contre de
véritables the en chocolat
récoltés vont
ils prendre des heures
polystyrène et on vient d'aisé et gérer
compte entre des heures chocolat
il expliqué les ramasser mes yeux
c'était un petit peu
sport avec une petite fille de 3 ans il
fallait se jeter dans la foule pourquoi
aller chercher les oeufs mais non non
c'est un bon moment en famille ici pas
de perdant tout le monde a eu droit à du
chocolat une deuxième édition pour une
chasse aux oeufs qui a su rassembler
comme un échauffement pour les enfants
avant que le lapin de pâques passe dans
leur jardin
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouver nicolas quirion vite pour le
7-8 société il vous parlera avec ses
invités du sidaction qui a lieu ce
week-end c'est la fin à présent de cette
édition je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau journal à revoir